[Music]
a grocery store now open in a
neighborhood that desperately needed one
the aftermarket as it's called will be a
game changer as people near Nellis Air
Force Base have had to make long
commutes to get their food the store is
located on Las Vegas Boulevard North off
Craig and as eight news now reporter
Victoria Saha shares the store has more
than one purpose
[Applause]
the aftermarket closing the gap on food
insecurity I really don't care what I
get right now I'm just happy that we got
a grocery store and a need for this area
of town before this Market even opened
and getting just a gallon of milk was a
challenge for the residents in this area
as the closest grocery store was six
miles away many of the residents don't
have their own transportation by time
you make it back home not until my 10 if
you ain't cooking your food right then
and there or putting it up in the
freezer it'd go bad and sometimes the
long wait for the bus wasn't doable for
Eric McCoy I go hungry a lot of them
shop at even your 7-Elevens or different
things like that trying to make it work
because there's nothing in the community
Dwayne McCoy is the owner he says the
store has just as many items as the big
Grocers this isn't the drive up food
line that screams poverty this is a
market the aftermarket is also a food
pantry for those who run out of money
and still need a market that's where the
name the aftermarket actually comes from
now for folks like Eric who had spent
hours getting to the store can come
whenever he needs to probably three or
four times a week Victoria welcome to
the aftermarket 8 News Now